first i want to talk about the abuse of
kiyosama last night the labour leader
surrounded by protesters let's remind
people of what happened
[Music]
should be surrounded by
a mob as we're seeing now on your screen
uh clearly subjecting him to harassment
and intimidation that has no place in a
democracy
and i think all of us across the
political spectrum should unreservedly
uh condemn what we saw there i think the
police made a couple of arrests which
i'm i'm glad to hear but no one in
public life should face that sort of uh
intimidation and harassment at all is
completely unacceptable this is why it
happened boris johnson in the house
this leader of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions mr
speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile
i should apologize well look i don't
think you can say that's why it happened
because some of the people involved in
that um that fracker you showed a second
ago you know that they were have
previously you know they were talking
about have previously done similar
things to people like michael gove and
bbc journalist uh nick what
i've listened to i've listened i've
listened to the whole tape i've listened
to the whole tape and they did mention
jimmy savile they did mention that they
also mentioned julian assange repeatedly
they mentioned
uh covid they mentioned the opposition
more generally and so i don't think you
can point uh to what the prime minister
said as the cause of that you certainly
can't blame him for the fact um that mob
were clearly behaving in a totally
unacceptable way for what he said
uh well i think what the prime minister
has done already last week is clarified
what he meant i'm glad you said that
because we've got that that was in
blackpool
i'm talking not about uh the leader of
the opposition's personal
um
record when he was uh when he was dpp uh
and i and i totally understand that he
had nothing to do
personally with those decisions
goes no way far enough yeah well i think
it does because it explains that he
wasn't suggesting that kyocerma
personally individually took the
decision on the jimmy savile prosecution
but kiyosama his own website chambers
website says he was responsible overall
for the cps in fact kirsten himself
apologized for the cps's failings just
in the same way that the prime minister
has apologized for the failings in
number 10 downing street in the last
couple of years so i don't think what he
said particularly when clarified in the
way that you just demonstrated uh means
that what he said originally and was
misleading you certainly can't say that
what he said in any way prompted
provoked or justified
the harassment and intimidation we saw
last
it is a ridiculous slur peddled by
right-wing trolls
he just needs to apologize
yeah well the suggestion that kyocerma
personally took a decision on jimmy
savile is a slur
right is untrue um kierstahler is a is a
decent man who has uh director of the
cps uh was doing his best but there were
organizational failings
at the cps which kirsten himself i think
a few years subsequently um apologized
for so i think you know with that
clarification that the prime minister
made a couple of days later
that is an accurate representation then
of what happened not according and i
don't think in any way justified or
provoked or incited the terrible and
totally unacceptable harassment and
intimidation of the leader of the
opposition we saw last night this is not
what the mayor of london thinks sadiq
khan said this is what happens when fake
news is amplified and given credibility
by people who should know better but not
just him nicholas sturgeon saying um if
he has any decency at all the pm will
now apologize unreservedly and sir ed
davies saying the fact that they were
allegedly shouting jimmy savile shows
that boris johnson's words have real
life consequences yeah well i've
listened to the whole tape and they did
mention jimmy savelle that is true that
was they also spent most of the time
when they were harassing uh poor
kirstarma there talking about julian
assange lockdown
goodness knows what else and the same
people though some of the same people
who were harassing and intimidating
kierstarma had done the same thing
to michael govind to bbc journalist nick
was these are people who've got a i'm
afraid sadly a track record of behaving
in that appalling way towards public so
those are three leaders who i've told
you who disagree not just labor smp and
lib dems this was a julian smith mp uh
last night what happened to his drama
tonight outside parliament is
appalling uh is what he said he was
appalling it was appalling and he went
on to say it's really important for our
democracy and for his security that the
false savile slurs made against him are
withdrawn in full not just him we also
heard from tobias elwood last night and
this is what sir demaious elwood was
saying
apologize please we claim to be the
mother of all parliaments let's stop
this drift towards a trumpian
style of politics from becoming the norm
we are better than this yeah and that is
why last week the prime minister
clarified very clearly is your clip
as your as your clip shot good enough
that he wasn't that he wasn't suggesting
that kia stammer personally took
decisions about jimmy savile but the cps
which he ran overall did have
organizational failings and that's what
he was pointing to
um i've just illustrated with at least
seven people who are all senior members
of whatever party they're a member of
all unite to say prime minister you need
to apologize yeah well like well i've
heard those comments and you know i've
said that and they're all right
terrified are they all
that he look he clarified his comments
i've heard his clarification
last week to make clear what he meant
and i think and the prime minister came
out yesterday and very clearly said
yesterday evening that what happened to
kierstarma that have terrible harassment
and intimidation is completely
unacceptable uh whether it's the leader
of the opposition whether it's michael
gove whether it's journalists like nick
watt it just should not be happening on
our streets and i'm glad that the police
have made arrests as a result we haven't
met before minister and i'm sorry to put
you on the spot here but you are
defending the indefensible
i don't think so i've explained how the
prime minister clarified what he said he
went back on the record a couple of days
after he made the initial remarks
to make sure there was no
misunderstanding because the thing he
said i think it was monday of last week
that the first clip you played in
parliament could have been misconstrued
as suggesting that kiestama personally
took a decision
those are the slur online slurs that
kissed armor himself referred to and the
prime minister quite rightly came back
and clarified that is not what he meant
he was talking about the general
responsibility for the organization not
the any specific personal involvement so
he went back and he rightly clarified
that within a couple of days to make
sure there was no misunderstanding the
second most important person in
government his next door neighbor also
said that he would not have said it
yeah he did say that that's right okay
everybody apart from the prime minister
and it would seem you today uh feel that
it
the uh leader of the opposition deserves
an apology
well i mean the chancellor didn't say he
deserves an apology he said he wouldn't
personally um have said it and people
make their own choices about what to say
um but i think you know if you look at
his clarification
look i mean it's his choice to make the
comment that he made um
in the heat of the debate uh he
clarified a couple of days later exactly
what he meant but there is no way anyone
reasonably can suggest that what he said
incited or justified or prompted a list
of people who think that it is
reasonable to make that i don't think i
don't think you can
make the leap
from commenting on someone's record as
dpp um or commenting on what happened to
the dpp while he was in charge of it um
being clear that it wasn't him
personally who took the decision on
jimmy savile um to harassment and
intimidation so just to clarify the
mayor of london the leader of the
scottish nationals the leader of the
liberal democrats a very senior
conservative who used to be a minister
and a chief whip and the
chairman of the defence select committee
are all wrong
yeah i just don't think you can you can
say that the comments the prime minister
made about kirsten's record as dpp or
the crown prosecution services record
can can reasonably be said to have
prompted
the terrible harassment and intimidation
that we just saw people get had their
record criticized the whole time who
criticized the prime minister's record
the whole time politicians get
criticized the whole time and you don't
sort of say well that justifies
a mob surrounding the politician in the
way that we just saw
oh i'm not that's not what i'm saying to
you what i'm saying to you is are all of
these people that i've quoted to you who
feel so strongly about it that they
actually put it into writing on twitter
last night are they all wrong
yeah look as i said i don't think you
can make a link reasonably between what
the prime minister said and the
harassment and intimidation this group
of people there were talking about a
number of things beyond as well as jimmy
savile they're people who have harassed
other
public figures including journalists
over the last uh year or two and so i
don't think you could make that living
when it came to the journalists and when
it came to other people that they were
harassing did they mention jimmy savile
then
well they mentioned all kinds of things
as they did
well no because that wasn't an issue at
the time but
the harassment exactly the hang on the
harassment last night they were talking
about a whole number of things they've
talked about they mostly talk about
julian assange if you listen to the
entire clip they were mostly going on
about julian assange for some reason
they were harassing the leader of her
majesty's opposition which is totally
unacceptable
he needed to get police protection he
needed to be whisked off in a police
vehicle they talked to him about jimmy
savile
and that was brought up by the prime
minister at the dispatch box last week
the deputy the um shadow foreign
secretary caught up in the melee as well
several people from all
persuasions of parliament and up in
scotland as well and the mayor of london
all saying this is unacceptable and it's
a direct result of what happened with
the prime minister's comments on jimmy
savile and he needs to apologize
well i i i are defending the
indefensible there is no way the leader
of the opposition or any mp in public
life or indeed anyone at all including
journalists
should suffer the kind of intimidation
and harassment that kierstarma suffered
on the clip that you're you're showing
no way that should happen it's totally
wrong however i don't think you can say
that that was caused by the prime
minister's comments because these people
because these people other people are
saying well i don't think i'm not saying
well i don't think they should say it
either because the people who undertook
that terrible intimidation and
harassment are people who've got a long
track record of doing exactly the same
thing they've been doing that long
before the prime minister made a
reference to jimmy savage are you doing
it to people in my case if the prime
minister didn't think he was wrong why
did he clarify the situation in
blackpool well he clarified the
situation because i think the comments
he made the previous monday
were capable of being potentially
misinterpreted as meaning that
kierstarma had individually somehow been
involved in that case so she was she's
not which is not true yeah which which
is not true he wasn't and there are
there have been online uh slurs as
kiersten
what he said could have been
misinterpreted that way and that is why
he came out in blackpool in the second
clip you played very clearly saying that
he's not he was not suggesting and does
not suggest okay that kirstarma
personally got involved in that but he
obviously was responsible for the cps as
a whole and kirsten himself subsequently
apologized for the cps's failings in
this area okay let's talk about the
online safety bill which is why you're
here today i'm sure my viewers have
their own views on what happened last
night
robust age verification measures is what
being told about the build will that go
far enough
yes it will this is a huge um step
forward to protect children
we are very worried about the way that
large numbers of children
access pornography sometimes extreme
pornography i think 51
of 11 to 13 year olds
have accessed uh porn online which is of
enormous concern to parents we think
that is completely wrong and the
measures we're going to be introducing
to parliament shortly and the updated
online safety bill will impose an
absolute obligation
on companies all companies
carrying pornography whether it's
user-generated content on social media
or commercial pornography sites it'll
cover everything will be required to
make sure uh people under the age of 18
uh children cannot access pornography
it'll be the first time
in this country we've legislated in that
way
and we know parents will welcome this
the police will welcome it teachers will
welcome it and it's a massive step
forward uh for protecting our children
okay um we've been talking about it for
a decade not likely to come in until
about 2025. uh why is it taking so long
well there were some provisions in the
digital economy act about four years ago
three years ago but those didn't go far
enough they didn't cover for example
social media platforms which obviously
is a huge source of pornography that
children end up looking at so we decided
we needed to go a lot further and cover
all forms of online pornography which
this so we took the opportunity of
updating it in this new bill we intend
to introduce this new bill to parliament
in the coming weeks uh we hope it will
have very broad-based
uh cross-party support we'll get it
through parliament as quickly as we
possibly can i hope this calendar year
through both houses and then get it
implemented as quickly after that as we
can so it's a huge step forward to
protect children i think 80 of adults
support the idea of age verification
that is to say making sure that people
under 18 can't see pornography so
there's huge public support for this and
you know we've seen stories about uh
sexual harassment sexual assaults in
schools increasing in recent years part
of the reason for that the police think
is the exposure
uh of pornography to children and that's
why it's so important that we take this
like very firm step to make sure they
just can't see this sort of material
online under the age of 18. okay i'm a
pussycat really so let's can i play some
music to finish if you'd like to here we
go
it's a bit unexpected
[Music]
i like this song
i do like it actually okay the prime
minister likes it apparently so i hear
yeah he sang it to his new head of comms
so here yeah do you think he's taking
the mickey out of all of us
no i don't i think it was a moment of
lightness in what was also quite a
stressful time
um for a lot of people in public life
and i don't think we should
criticize somebody for a
moment of levity during uh what is
probably quite a stressful working day
it's not in his gift though is it really
whether he survives or not
well uh you know we'll we'll see what
happens but i i hope and expect that he
will
and i don't think we should say we
didn't criticize someone for for having
a moment of lightness i think
everybody's working day i hope including
yours there are moments of lightness in
what can be quite a stressful yes there
are what about you not coming on this
show either i have yes
but uh except in the shower um but
everyone needs needs away i think of of
letting off steam i mean all of us i
think in different ways have quite
stressful working lives trust me you
wouldn't want me to sing there would be
nothing no i think you should i think
you should i could not carry a tune in a
bucket maybe i remember alok sharma
agreeing to do islands in the stream
with me at karaoke at christmas once
uh
thankfully for everybody the pandemic
happened you didn't
nice to talk to you thanks very much for
coming